et pour terminer à grand plongeon dans
l'univers la nasa a lancé aujourd'hui en
effet son nouveau télescope spatial
c'est un engin à infrarouge et c'est ce
qui fera la différence
dorénavant grâce à ces observations les
astronomes vont peut-être pouvoir
découvrir des astres lointains des
astres fois qui datent de l'origine du
monde patrick besseyre 12h10 un peu plus
avec ce décollage parfaitement réussi la
nasa a renoué ce matin avec le succès
après 8 minutes de vol cette fusée delta
2 va déposer en orbite un nouveau
télescope spatial infrarouge
celui ci a pour mission se lancer à
l'assaut des secrets de l'évolution de
l'univers syrte
c'est son nom de guerre va rester à la
dérive derrière la terre en suivant la
même trajectoire que notre planète dans
sa course autour du soleil en prenant
soin que le télescope reste en
permanence dos au soleil pour rester à
une température de moins 200 68 degrés
celsius
car ce nouveau télescope doit étudier
les objets les plus froids de l'univers
ceux qui sont trop froid pour émettre
une lumière visible
l'ancien et fameux télescope spatial
hubble lui réalisait des vues de
l'univers visible c'est à dire composé
de lumière comme celle que nous pouvons
voir avec nos yeux pour hubble
le cosmos est essentiellement vide noir
est parsemé de points de lumière que
sont les étoiles
maintenant voici un chat filmé en
infrarouge bien sûr nos yeux ne le vois
pas comme cela il faut une caméra
sensibles aux rayonnements infrarouges
pour l'univers c'est pareil là où une
belle voix du noir le nouveau télescope
infrarouge doit découvrir beaucoup
d'autres objets célestes les plus
lointains et donc les plus anciens les
plus froids et même des disques de
poussières qui en s'agglomérant finiront
par former des planètes
les astronomes américains qui
travaillent sur ce projet d'un milliard
deux cents millions d'euros espère même
découvrir pourquoi pas une soeur jumelle
à la terre